this week on quadriga swiss vote alarm
bells in europe in a tight fort
referendum the people of Switzerland
have voted to begin restricting
immigration and to reintroduce job
quotas favoring Swiss citizens is it a
sign of growing xenophobia or a reaction
to the march of globalization a victory
for direct democracy or proof of its
limitations
Brussels has already announced it will
review relations with Bern will vote
undermine ties between the EU and
Switzerland your host this week Ali
Aslan hello and welcome to quadriga it's
not every day that Switzerland this
nation of 8 million is dominating the
global headlines but it did so this week
when the Swiss voted on a controversial
referendum curtailing curtailing
immigration from the European Union so
what consequences will this referendum
have on the nation's relationship with
the European Union that's what we want
to talk about onto the show together
with these three individuals who've been
following the story very closely
welcome to Stefano caserta know who's
the International correspondent for the
Italian newspaper linky esta and a
columnist for the German News News
magazine the European he also teaches
international politics at Potsdam
University
olynyk Schmidt is the Berlin
correspondent for the Swiss newspaper
neue zürcher zeitung born and raised in
Zurich he has been an international
correspondent for the nzz since 1991
including postings in Moscow Washington
and Beijing and David charter is the
Berlin correspondent for the British
daily newspaper The Times and the author
of the book will have WA Y what if
Britain left the you question mark
welcome to the show or lachemann the
swiss voted to reintroduce immigration
quotas and in effect in doing so
invalidated the EU Swiss agreement on
freedom of movement let's look at the
reasoning first before we get into the
far-reaching consequences this deal
might have on the nation's relationship
with the European Union why did the
Swiss vote the way they did for various
reasons of course I think you really
first sociological studies already show
that or other clearly that there have
been several sources let's start with
the racists of course I mean you always
have those who don't like the foreigners
and I think Switzerland in this respect
is just like any other European
countries we have those problems we
haven't got them any stronger than in
other countries but they are existent
then I would say you have the large mass
of those who are really or feel
threatened by the existence of
foreigners in Switzerland that calm as
we've mentioned to 23.5%
about now that is more than in any other
European country excluding Luxembourg
and Liechtenstein and the comparability
of Luxembourg and Liechtenstein of
course is limited with Switzerland I
myself when I come to Switzerland when I
come to Zurich my hometown sometimes
have a little bit of a problem realizing
that what has changed its immense that
the change sometimes you don't hear
Swiss German for for quite a while in
the in
quick transport system or so undeniably
the Swiss economic boom has had a lot
you know affected the Swiss countryside
perhaps we can talk about this later so
this is another this is another point I
mean a lot of people just feel somehow
alienated in their own country and
without being racists whatsoever they
have decided that okay now we should
limit the flow into Switzerland a little
bit we will see whether this sentiment
is restricted only to Switzerland or
perhaps is not symptomatic for the
European Union as a whole David charter
but let's look at the numbers of this
vote which was led by the initiative by
the Swiss People's Party only 50 or
rather 50.3% voted in favor and 49.7
voted against this motion that means
only a 30 thousand votes difference
between the yes and no votes but of
course according to Swiss law it's
binding now because the majority whether
it's by three votes or 30,000 votes
doesn't really matter did it surprise
you that the Swiss voted to define their
own government and their own business
community both of whom have pleaded not
to vote for this motion I think perhaps
you shouldn't find it that surprising
because it's a similar majority a very
small majority to the amount that
rejected joining the European Economic
Area when when when the Swiss were
offered the chance to join the single
market and let's be honest it's the
single market that has the freedoms of
movements that have over over the years
that it's been in in in force in
Switzerland since 2002 have have led to
these problems and and that
controversies in Switzerland and I'll
you emphasize that it's a small majority
I think it was it was less than 20,000
people the actual majority but of course
the volume of votes that that passed the
measure was of course over a million and
it's it's it you know there is that
there's a substantial feeling in
Switzerland as there is in many Europe
countries that the freedom the wholesale
freedom of movement without restriction
should have some limits if possible and
the limits will now be in effect in
Switzerland Stefano Caserta know also
very interesting to see how this vote
played out geographically speaking with
in Switzerland the french-speaking parts
voted against the measure whereas the
German in Italian speaking parts of
Switzerland voted primarily to impose
the restrictions on immigration now
you're from Italy and you know the Swiss
border with Italy very well did it
surprise you that particularly the
Italian speaking part voted in favor of
this motion yes and no I mean it's it's
not any Italian community so to say
they're not Italians they speak Italian
they look at Island sometime but it's
they perceive themselves as a different
cultural cluster from from Italy and
somehow I must say these people anyhow
have the sensibility to perceive that
something is going on in Italy they are
perceiving the increase in immigration
from bordering countries so I think that
culturally speaking social is being
sociologically speaking this is an
understandable reaction sadly it is an
understandable reaction Systema no
Caserta no also look at the facts since
you are from Zurich your hometown as you
said all the big cities in Switzerland
that have large portions of foreigners
Basel Geneva Zurich they all voted
against the motion to impose this this
restriction on immigration whereas the
more rural areas were lesser foreigners
live voted in favor that seems to be a
rather contradictory notion it's
essentially interesting I think to say
that the areas where most you know in
the in the Swiss German part of
Switzerland the big thing of course was
the Germans because we've had in the
last 10 15 years we have this in
enormous influx of Germans sometimes
monthly about 3,000 people came to
Switzerland and now the Germans make up
the the second largest group within
Switzerland the biggest are the Italians
and still roughly about three hundred
thousand two hundred ninety thousand I
think and they come the Germans and this
is Swiss germs of course with their very
very difficult to relationship to the
Germans into which I will not go now
there a lot of this Senna phobia
manifested itself but interesting love
yeah in the city in the big cities in
the big agglomerations where most of the
Germans lived you had an auntie vote
against the mass emigration initiative
which shows to a certain extent of
course that the Swiss are not Cinna
phobic the Senna phobia lied as again
everywhere in Europe there where there
are no foreigners that they are against
the foreigners there where the where no
foreigners are where the the knowledge
the everyday knowledge of getting you
know you know going into a beer together
hasn't been there yeah
and David charter the initial impulse is
to reject and criticize the decision by
the Swiss people at least if you look at
the global headlines but let's look at
the numbers and perhaps we'll understand
a bit more in 2013 eighty thousand
immigrants came to Switzerland as has
already been mentioned twenty-three
percent of Switzerland's population is
foreign in Germany for instance
comparatively speaking it's only
approximately nine percent and the the
population in Switzerland has hiked from
seven to eight million in a time span of
only a decade all these fears and
concerns that Switzerland is perhaps
losing its identity if you will
aren't they perhaps legitimate of course
there's some legitimacy in its national
sovereignty is one of the the big forces
at work here in in this issue as it as
it is in many countries let's just be a
little bit careful about saying that 23%
of the Swiss are foreigners because you
know
that the Swiss are very reluctant to
give out their passports so in other
countries where foreigners have arrived
they are able to be naturalized and to
get the passport of that country much
more easily than they are in Switzerland
so the apparent number of natural light
of citizens of those other countries is
lower than it is in Switzerland we have
we have to say that having said that
Switzerland has always really based its
whole national identity on being
somewhat a little different to everyone
else around it and that that that is a
very there's a very strong identity so
it's it's hardly surprising that in a
modern world where there's so many more
interconnections between people and
people expect with the Schengen
Agreement for example to drive from one
end of Europe to the other without
having to produce a passport that there
is some reaction against this so I think
again I think it's a I do think is an
understandable vote and you have to look
at it from the perspective of a country
that has decided not to join the
European Union they have decided not to
take part fully in a single market or
the four freedoms there are there is a
hierarchy among these freedoms we don't
have a freedom of movement of capital
and financial services from Switzerland
they haven't been able to join that
properly because of their own unique
circumspect banking circumstances and
now they think well perhaps we can also
modify the freedom of movement of people
as we have with capital to suit
ourselves surely that's what being
outside of the European Union should
allow us to do and 7or there are some
people who even fear now for the
national unity of switzerland since they
voted so strictly along ethnic and
linguistic lines they're saying in
essence this reveals once more that
Switzerland is not one country but many
countries sort of lumped together into
one territory do you think these fears
and concerns are are justifiable and
understandable please correct me if I'm
mistaken but I guess that Switzerland
has always been like that so it's part
of the very essence of the national
spirit
branding a different binding different
nationality so to say so I think it will
just go on to be like that and overall I
would say this is a transnational
tendency so if you take a look also at
Italy southern Italy northern Italy or
even the competition between Rome and
Milan so people are trying to look to
justify their identity looking at what's
happening in their city or even in the
neighborhood
so if Romans now are starting to feel
more romance than Italians at least in
Switzerland a yeah limited to four
different nationalities and that's good
enough
perhaps I'll add here that you know it's
a little bit when you when you look at
the yes/no distinction and you color one
green and the other one red and you have
this very very clear oh my god you know
there's a clear divide between
Switzerland yeah but when you look at
the percentages you will see that a few
percentage points are between the the
areas and as you say totally correctly I
mean has always been you can you can see
that in practically every vote in
Switzerland that the home or as we call
them the Roman the french-speaking and
also very much the Italian speaking
population vote tends to vote a little
bit differently and they saw that issue
but in essence you know like it's the
country falling apart I mean we do not
have a problem like for instance Belgium
in in Geneva you have from time to time
people that you know sort of look to
France and and you hear from time to
time oh how would it be if we were in
France and then there are they're
starting to ask themselves the question
really how would it be if you were in
France well terrible we would be a
little tiny country somewhere in the
east of France
now with Geneva in Switzerland so no
this is not gonna come true you know
well I've lived in Brussels in Belgium
and you're right that the the
nationalist forces are much stronger at
dividing Brussels Belgium a bigger pond
but the
the willow nyan section of Belgium looks
to France they don't actually want to be
subsumed in and be a tiny little
department of France that gets
overlooked somewhere on on the border so
you can well understand why that the
Swiss hang together of course well
here's what the supporters are saying
overly Schmidt and you can back them up
or refute him on this but this is when
you ask people on the street at least
those who are willing and blunt to speak
out about why they voted in favor of
curtailing immigration this is what they
say they say foreigners cause huge hike
in rents rent now has been is largely
unaffordable because of that they put
pressure on the health education system
on transportation and they drive the
salaries down so this is basically the
arguments that the supporters of this
motions are putting forth do they have a
point I want to make it clear that I
voted against this initiative not to you
know to have a false impression here
look it's it's all lumped together this
has to do with the economy Switzerland
has decided for many reasons that it
wants to have a booming liberal economy
Switzerland is so to say the only really
liberal country on the continent Great
Britain is the other one but it's not a
continent and it's not just the result
of those agreements with the EU that
boosted Switzerland's economy so
magnificently after 2000 this was one of
the reasons so the answer to that no
it's not the foreigners that drive up
the rains etc it's the economy which
again depends on the influx of many
thousands of foreigners we need them our
economy that has groans you know rather
heavily in the last few years and and
the very high prices and everything you
know it's all connected together so they
are a result of that and in and to blame
them as as foreigners
I think is totally ludicrous stefano
castle this is exactly what the business
community in switzerland is also putting
forth as an argument they're saying
switzerland will suffer the the Swiss
economy will suffer as a result of this
vote because now we can no longer
attract the qualified labor that is
needed they say this will undermine
Swiss economy did the people who voted
in favor of this referendum not think
this through properly I think that
normally when this kind of decisions are
made by by the population people that
vote in favor of such resolutions people
with lower wages lower level of
education and people that perceive the
competition of people coming from from
abroad what I'm concerned about is that
Switzerland is somehow aiming at a model
it's very close to the United Arab
Emirates so you have national workers
and you have international workers
international workers we have two
classes you have the Westerners and the
Australians of course and lots of them
and then you have people from the
Philippines people people from from
Pakistan that go there and work a lower
wages so I'm afraid that Switzerland is
started to think it can behave like that
and offshore it cannot because they have
no oil and the notion that the
foreigners are taking away jobs seems a
bit irrational perhaps to say the least
when you look at the unemployment
figures in Switzerland which are around
3% compared that to 11% in the European
Union because according to the census
now employers must give priority to
Swiss citizens yeah it's the it's the
called the lump of labour fallacy by
economists the idea that there is a set
number of jobs and however many people
leave or or arrive in the country
there's always a set number of jobs has
has been proven over the years to be
false and the the number of people who
arrived in the country is linked to the
creation of jobs and it stands to reason
as you say Switzerland has the lowest
employment unemployment of any country
in Europe and I think perversely it will
become more attractive to immigrants
if it moves to a quota system because
there will then be a fierce competition
to get those places in the high highest
paying lowest unemployment country in in
Europe so I think Switzerland although
it has no oil can actually get away with
behaving like like an Emirates and David
Chara let's look at perhaps the most
crucial aspects of this this vote namely
Switzerland's relationship with the EU
because this vote in essence invalidates
the Swiss EU agreement on freedom of
movement and might have impact on Swiss
access to Europe single market which
would be detrimental because if we look
at the numbers EU is the biggest trading
partner of Switzerland approximately 60%
of all Swiss goods go into the single
market how detrimental do you think will
this be to Switzerland as a country and
particularly its economy I think that
the EU has got a problem because it
cannot be seen to allow one country to
try and cherry-pick everything it wants
from the e use advantages however
Switzerland is not an is not an EU
country and the grown-up thing to do is
to reach to renegotiate the relationship
between the countries in a sensible
fashion that shouldn't harm those EU
countries which board US border
Switzerland and which are their
governments the government of Italy for
example will very much be arguing in
Brussels that Italians should still have
the ability to freely cross the border
to go to work to do
that the jobs that they do on on a daily
basis whilst living in Italy and the
same go the same go to France and
Germany so that we there will be
pressure in Brussels not to punish from
the member states not to punish switch
them very hard but if I refer to my own
to the out of the situation in my own
country in Great Britain because of this
this the agitation in Great Britain that
to limit freedom of movement of people
Brussels will have to be
seem to be acting in some way and there
are some vulnerable aspects of the deal
such as Switzerland's access to the
enormous research budget of the European
Union which is something like seven or
eight billion euros over the next seven
years switz and has a really good set
has really good access to that in the
last period and to find itself having
more trouble with this university
researchers joining projects would be
quite devastating I think and Ola
Schmitt there are some signs for things
to come for Switzerland EU leaders in
the immediate aftermath of this vote
have already said that they can no can
no longer be access to EU single market
without freedom of movement what is the
mood in Switzerland these days is a more
defiant
or or maybe a bit of a sober mood now
you know sort of like the morning after
a big big big night out partying yeah
I've discerned a little bit of a sober
mood now yes in Switzerland there's a
lot of discussions there's a lot of heat
going on between the the parties but of
course let's see that first of all the
Swiss federal counts from the government
now has to work out those contingencies
it has to work out everything that has
been in the initiative or isn't
initiative that has been accepted by the
people and interestingly enough the AS
VAL pay the populist party has given
that initiated the initiative has given
the government three years to work out
those those rules that it wants to come
that once you confirm to EU with and
that is a long time and somehow I've got
the impression that Brussels and unburn
that have a long tradition of agreement
and of negotiating with each other and
that like each other because Switzerland
in Brussels is seen as a very good
partner it's reliable Switzerland pays
for its goods which when you make a
contract with Switzerland well it's
there it holds you know isn't it so so I
think it'll take some time
work out these things and that soup is
going to be eaten only half as warm as
it was cooked well we'll see how the
soup will taste in the immediate
aftermath of this referendum in which
many leading EU politicians and
individuals have spoken out mostly
against the census including politicians
in Germany of course let's have a look
at what they had to say Switzerland must
realize that cherry-picking with the EU
is not a long-term strategy we want fair
relations with a non-eu member such as
Switzerland fair relations mean that one
has to be willing to accept the burdens
or disadvantages alongside the
advantages
this is a difficult vote for Europe I
believe Switzerland did not do itself a
favor
but I would be careful with pointing the
finger at Switzerland because I believe
that such attitudes don't only exist
there these attitudes and these fears
exist and they have a little to do with
the fact that in today's totally open
globalization it's convenient for
populist s-- to exploit the situation a
large majority of the German population
does not think immigration is a problem
in Germany that's why this is a
situation specific to Switzerland and we
should not and must not think it is
transferable to Germany while they were
charter you just heard Germany's
interior minister Thomas de maizière
saying this is particularly a Swiss
phenomenon this is a Swiss problem but
there's some out there who are saying
not so fast in quite there are many who
argue that this result the outcome would
have been pretty much the same in any
other a EU nation if they had held the
vote would you agree i I do agree I
think it's a very complacent statement
from Thomas de Maiziere because there's
no way that Germany is going to offer
its citizens a referendum on on this or
any other matter constitutionally it
wouldn't happen in Germany I don't think
but if it if it was to be the case that
there were referendums now in different
European countries on the freedom of
movement of people the unrestricted
freedom of movement you would find that
there are many more there are many close
results like Switzerland and in many
countries I Great Britain from France
I'm sure that it would be very tough to
win a referendum like that and it's
because of course we've been through
four or five years of recession and
downturn and the popular mood is one of
scapegoating looking for people to blame
for what's gone wrong I mean the
politicians clearly do get a lot of
blame but if people get a chance to
blame the European Union in a referendum
and that's how it will be seen it will
be seen as a vote on the performance of
the European Union then I can't see the
the the referendums being won because
the European Union is in it certainly in
my country and Great Britain is
indelibly linked with the difficulties
of the euro and the in enormous
unemployment rates in southern Europe
that have triggered the migration of
many of these people to look for a
better life to look for a for a job for
a better paid job and the policy of
freedom of movements was brought in when
there were six member states that were
broadly comparable with their economies
their earnings expectations but has been
left unchanged while we've moved to 28
member states some of which have income
levels and expectations well a third of
what of what it is in Western Europe
seven of many Europe Euroskeptics
outside of Switzerland have embraced
this notion in particular in Germany the
so called alternative for Germany of
course the UKIP
in Great Britain had builders in
Netherlands marine lepen
in France they've all been very quick to
embrace this notion and have called for
such a vote to take place in their own
country and as well there's justified or
not there seems to be a growing
uneasiness with the notion of
immigration in all European countries do
politicians take this uneasiness serious
enough I think they must take it into
account if you see the sea to liquid
look at the situation in Germany the
interesting thing is that they're
actually criticizing they've been some
some a stream of opinion last year
criticising the free circulation of
capital actually why because people were
perceiving that capital flowing in from
southern Europe was making real-estate
prices soar so that's why people were
dissatisfied with that of course the way
in Switzerland you say you cannot have
free movement of capital without free
movement of people because the up
for Germany so I must say yes it's a
vote of Switzerland it's not just a
Swiss matter is a vote against Europe
it's setting an example and not by
chance the only country
you didn't mention Ally what was Italy
in Italy leg an order which is close to
the end paid a position the National
Democratic Party of Germany far-right a
party in Germany actually endorsed the
the Swiss decision this is a big problem
if I might add something if Switzerland
and Europe have to break the agreement
about the free circulation of capital
this will be in a time of crisis a big
favor to Europe because Italian
companies are migrating to Switzerland
capitals are migrating to Switzerland
because of tax advantages if something
like this happens this flow is going to
stop and European countries will have
free hand to increase taxes and this is
what's going what's happened in the last
years so the Swiss should be afraid of
what they wish for this notion David
Charter because you wrote a book about
that what if Britain left the EU's so
certainly this anti you sentiment is
widespread Europe but certainly in your
country in Great Britain the politicians
there must must have followed this
referendum very closely haven't they
very close in theirs there's actually
been a deafening silence from a lot of
the leading politicians because what it
does do and the reason why the UK
Independence Party were overjoyed is
that it shows the power of a country
that is not in the European Union to
regain control if you like over its
national borders over who enters and
leaves the country which is the big
selling points of the UK Independence
Party you have to leave not only the
European Union you have to leave the
single markets to be able to do that you
can't do you can't as the Prime Minister
David Cameron is suggesting you cannot
limit in the free movement of people
effective
if you are a European Union member and
remain a member of the European Union
it's pretty clear it's been made very
clear by many senior politicians in
Brussels and other European countries
that that's not acceptable you can only
do it by leaving and this the
Switzerland case makes makes points very
clearly for the UK Independence Party
and I might add in the run-up to the
European elections which are just around
the corner there in May and we're
expecting the greatest return of
populist and anti-european EU and T EU
candidates that we've ever seen and this
Swiss referendum might have indeed given
a boost to anti Europeans out there
shortly before the election in May or
Leishman the question now on everyone's
mind is how well Brussels reacts and the
notion out there is that if the EU is
striking a compromise would strike a
compromise with Switzerland this would
set a bad example so this would better
set a bad example because other European
nations would follow suit knowing that
they have nothing to fear what's your
take yes the brussels is in a very very
difficult position at the moment because
exactly what you say i mean it's um
there is no cherry-picking the bilateral
one agreements of which freedom of
movement freedom of capital flow
services and finances they're all they
come in one packet and there is the
so-called guillotine clause that has
been signed that makes it very clear
that one cannot be left without touching
the others so yeah I mean what do you
want to do in such a situation it's
either/or it's a whole package and
Brussels has to probably has to show a
certain force on the other hand as I
said it's very difficult it wouldn't
surprise me that in an ongoing process
over the next three years people that
are accustomed to find compromises will
will actually also find compromises
because essentially you have to consider
that no one in Brussels is interested in
a week Switzerland know what nobody
really wants to bring Switzerland down
to its knees
we and you know you're in an awkward
position when you hear things like that
you know we inspire the European right
because again as I said in Switzerland a
large a very large part of that vote had
absolutely nothing to do with xenophobia
it was you know this is an aspect that
we haven't talked about Switzerland has
only about 15 to 18 thousand square
kilometers that can be settled all these
eight millions all these magnificent
I've recently traveled from from Zurich
to Geneva through Bern Lausanne and it's
immense you know it's one big a
collaboration this enormous BNP that
Switzerland produces which is you know
twice the one of France for instance
this has this shows on the on the ground
and that is an aspect that in Europe has
not you know rarely has been seen that
the Swiss are not so much concerned
about the forests they are concerned
about their own land we are making we
are finishing our land and this it's
called deep dish stress the stress of
density in Switzerland and that is an
aspect which is very important it has in
many aspects nothing to do with
right-wing politicians whatsoever and
this is what the people like me for
instance I have voted against the
initiatives don't like that we somehow
would inspire the right-wing coalition's
that exist all over Europe well this
distress or not Stefano Caserta know how
should Brussels react ah [ __ ] what kind
of decision should the EU put forth now
in response to the Swiss referendum is
really hope they are going to compromise
because they might want it or not desire
or not but with Switzerland is at least
your graphically part of Europe and
I think I'm also without the fact that
in the end although the first reaction
is a populist that's why the referendum
won I think that Switzerland will also
now start a debate to understand if
factual it is something that might work
we must not think that the fact that of
course this kind of referendums normally
are promoted by some sort of minority
party and they manage always to attract
a cluster of enraged people and that's
why I'm sure that if they did a
referendum next week then this
resolution would be rejected well that's
an interesting notion
David Charter because many people out
there whether or not they like the
results they hail the Swiss nonetheless
to have the courage to hold such
referendums but doesn't the results also
show the dangers of such system of
direct democracy it is a system that you
can't you shouldn't parachute into
another country I don't think I mean
it's not coincidental that it's one of
the main policies of the UK Independence
Party to introduce a similar system of
direct democracy and we all know that
there are there are many there are many
issues out there more to do perhaps with
human rights and that sort of thing that
that will get drawn into direct
democracy and become incredible
distractions and it could be incredibly
destructive for society if you're if
you're if you're if you have to read
read debate and renegotiate the death
penalty or the right to abortion or
something I mean these these these
things these things could be quite big
distractions from from the politics of
the day which is let's face it is fixing
the economy and making sure people have
got you know jobs and health service and
and schools but coming back to what the
EU should do I mean clearly from the
British perspective they do want to
encourage the British Euroskeptics or
the British withdraw a list to say hey
there's no problem with leaving there's
no problem with being Switzerland if
it's beneficial you can vote for what
you want and you get it so there has to
be consequences for Switzerland the
problem from Brussels is that these
consequences mustn't be consequences
which harm other EU citizens and other
EU member states like the border states
that need the free access and for their
people who travel and transport so quite
a dilemma that Brussels finds itself in
and we're very curious to see how this
all plays out Olli Schmidt you are a
global citizen of course your Swiss
citizen but due to your work as an
international correspond you worked in
Beijing Washington and so on so forth
how much does it hurt you to see now the
global headlines about Switzerland being
cast and labelled perhaps as a
xenophobic country well you know it's
bearable it has been around for quite a
while now we once I can remember the
times when Switzerland was sort of the
goody-goody of the world I mean you
showed your Swiss passport and everybody
you know was was happy and these times
are over we have become the villains in
many respects of Europe and it's somehow
fun because it's equally idiotic to you
know I mean to say our look at the Swiss
my god these these are awful people in
Switzerland but the Swiss are really bad
you know it's intellectually completely
hysterical position of course no we are
just like any other people but we do
live in other circumstances of course
and we do have direct democracy and
direct democracy is of course as you
said it's a an instrument that we've had
for a long long time and that in
Switzerland is totally approved now that
is a very interesting point there is
that's the only thing in Switzerland
where there is total and agreement among
all the parties from left to right we
like direct democracy it has been it is
considered and as being considered
considered a good tool to solve the
problems of Switzerland in the last you
know in the years since
18:48 and to see Switzerland now I don't
think by the way that Switzerland is
seen as a villain at all because that's
the headlines the politicians already
have been very very careful to condemn
Switzerland too much and when you look
at the people you see a very different
notion I mean the reactions we have now
we live in the Internet age and the
people very freely if their reactions
and I could see a lot of sympathy out
there for Switzerland so no it's not so
bad
not so bad stefano Castletown a quick
assessment do you as an Italian would
you like to see such an system being
implemented in your country would you
like to see more direct democracy in
Italy we already have it and we have
quite a lot of that I must say the up
and coming parties in Italy and
especially the betta grill of five star
movement is promoting this concept a lot
and it's bringing to I an extreme
ization of political position don't
forget it has always walked but we have
the internet nowadays and internet extra
Mises opinion so that's where the danger
of direct democracy democracy lies David
Schaad a quick assessment how would such
a vote play out in Britain if Great
Britain would have a whole public
referendum on immigration any referendum
that's linked with the European Union
apart from the big question of in or out
would be lost that there's no doubt in
my mind that the sentiments all the
Eurobarometer polls show it's the United
Kingdom has the the least feeling of
being citizens of the of the European
Union of having confidence in the
European Union and any referendum you
held that did not say do you want to
stay in or out it would certainly be
lost timing well we will of course see
what consequences this motion will have
on Switzerland's relationship with the
European Union but one thing is for sure
Switzerland will rely very much on its
foreigners come summer because that's
when the Swiss football national team
will compete in Brazil for the World Cup
and just a look at the now
team will reveal that the predominant
majority of the players have an ethnic
migrant background for that I want to
thank my guests for a very spirited
discussion on this motion thank you out
there for tuning in and looking forward
to seeing you again next week for a new
discussion on Patrika